the upcoming spring session graduate
course on transcriptomic data analysis
will start January 2020 in this course
we will explore how gene expression can
be studied using high-throughput
sequencing data by leveraging principles
of bioinformatics the course will cover
essential steps of processing analysis
and interpretation of such data using
commercial solutions for
high-performance computing such as T bio
info and open source applications such
as are the year 2020
marks a 70 year mark since the discovery
of the structure and function of the DNA
molecule it took almost 50 years from
that time to sequence the first human
genome but soon after the technology
develops started to evolve rapidly by
2015 the 1000 genome project brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018 over 100,000 whole genomes were
sequenced today there is an ever
increasing number of genomic
transcriptomics proteomics and made of
genomic data sets available to describe
subcellular processes with highly
detailed digital data the AMA x
technologies are used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells of an organism of omics data
can be generated using NGS or what is
also known as high-throughput sequencing
the data can show detailed information
about genomic variants epigenomic
regulation as well as gene and isoform
expression in this program we will focus
on one type of this data transcriptomics
the program will cover analysis of gene
expression data with practical sessions
and online tutorials anyone with a basic
knowledge of cell and molecular biology
will be able to conceptually understand
as well as practically apply standard
data analysis tools to process analyze
and interpret complex transcriptomics
data we will do so by leveraging regular
online webinars practical exercises and
online courses these resources provide a
broad and yet detailed overview of
processing statistical analysis machine
learning tools and single cell data
analysis techniques the
courses cover methods expand on various
terminologies provide practical examples
and offer quizzes for self-evaluation
starting on January 30th we will start
discussing the various aspects of RNA
seek data analysis and how this field of
bioinformatics continues to evolve this
technique has been refined over the
years and now is regularly used by many
scientists to perform in-depth analysis
of gene and isoform expression data in
addition to online courses all
participants will get access to hands-on
exercises and datasets for practice
these can be completed without any
coding using the analytical T bio info
platform that provides an interactive
learning experience a major topic of
analysis of transcriptomic data is
statistical analysis which is used for
identification of differentially
expressed genes and isoforms a number of
statistical tests allow us to compare
groups of samples under different
conditions but a variety of
considerations around data preparation
normalization and adjustments are going
to be important for these tests to be
applied properly the online session will
supplement information covered in the
transcriptomics one and transcriptomics
two modules available online but the
data offers more insight than one can
find in standard techniques exploring
data and understanding its statistical
properties can help us spot technical
variation that can have unwanted effects
on our analysis some of the techniques
we will learn to apply are easy to use
and can be done in Excel or any type of
table manipulation software others
require a basic understanding of our
libraries and how to deploy those in our
studio oftentimes statistical tests do
not capture the granularity of
expression data in a given data set to
learn about methods that can handle
complexity that is typical for large
omics data sets we will have to learn
about additional methods of
dimensionality reduction data mining and
classification as a result we can study
genes how they describe samples in our
data set and how this correlates with
phenotypic information we have for
biological or even clinical
interpretation in this course we will
also learn about other methods
including various approaches to
clustering and network analysis that can
be used to mine rich transcriptomic data
for meaningful patterns and use them to
classify new data for example a defined
pattern of expression can be linked to
other players and a regulatory network
affected by a condition we will also
learn about the impact of feature
selection on interpretation of a
condition sampled from various data sets
but ultimately we try to connect the
data with biology how can these genes
isoforms or their expression levels help
explain the mechanism of action explain
the process of deregulation of a vital
cellular pathway or provide an
indication that a gene or protein can be
considered as a target for a drug here
we will learn about various databases
that are used to annotate our data and
Link it to functional properties found
in gene ontology z' and pathways in this
course we will learn to utilize gene set
enrichment analysis to find pathways or
gene sets' enriched with up or down
regulated genes of interest learning
bioinformatics involves the
understanding of various environments
that make dealing with data possible
after the program we will include an
optional part where you can learn about
single cell transcriptomics we welcome
you to join us for this exciting course
register today and share this
information with friends and colleagues